open up the
door ma'am open up the
door
can can you put the car in park
please thank you uh how about you step
out for
me no you that's
reverse that's
Drive
Park it was in park there you
go
roll the window
down here turn the car
off step out of the
car where are you coming from tonight my
house where is your
house
okay 115 out with 105 let's go to the
front of your car over here we're going
to go to the front of your car okay how
much of it have you had to
drink more okay from at your house no
bar what
bar Ivy ivy okay what what town is that
in hon okay and where are you going to
now my house
uh how do you get to your
house car I know the car I know that but
like what roads you take to go to your
house nasau Street
to down to Washington Township to
Lawrence okay well you're in West
Windsor right now which is not that
direction and you're sleeping on the
side of the road in your car so uh we're
going to put you through some tests cuz
I don't think you should be driving and
uh obviously uh what tool is this Hawke
Elementary School in what township West
Windsor okay you should call my dad you
don't have to do any tests no we're
going to do some tests no you don't have
to do any tests I'll admit anything
okay come uh come into the front of your
car I'm going to check your eyes okay
it's okay I'm a treatment
what I'll admit to anything I don't I'm
not asking you to admit to anything I'm
going ask you to do a couple tests for
me
okay so I want you to lean on the front
of your car not on the side okay not I'm
going to Adit to anything um but you
should call my dad because
um
okay I'll admit to
anything I drove I drove junk okay well
I still have to do the
test do you not want to participate in
the tests no even if I check your
eyes I'll admit to it okay um you can
ask me okay well we're going to get to
there but again I want to give you
opportunity uh to do the tests and then
we'll take it from there okay so I'm
going to check your eyes first do you
have any conditions neological or
anything that affect your
eyes affect your
eyes in what
[Music]
way
man
I need you to keep your composure for a
second okay all right can you see the
tip of my pen no okay I want you to F
you said no or yes no you cannot see the
tip of my
pen the pen here in my hand you have
blue eyes I do I'm not asking you to
look at my eyes though I'm asking you to
look at the tip of my pen yeah I said no
you cannot see it okay all
right you want to do a walk and turn
test
no no why
not
huh where's your ID in the car it's
right here you have it in your pocket
yeah
okay
thank
you 515 237 copy on New New Jersey DL by
number
have B two hours away who does my
parents okay uh does somebody live
closer than that that you you're friends
with family member I live here okay all
right uh well you are going to be placed
under arrest for driving well
intoxicated okay all right um but once
we get back I have to put you on a
breath test I know after that somebody
has to come pick you up my parents will
they will okay so when we get back being
that they're far you'll call and then
we'll do the the breath test okay that
works can you uh turn around and place
your hands behind your
back that no I got it uh just you call
for 57 there the
ones okay all right we'll have them come
pick you up man I don't want you to go
to the road
okay car yeah your car is going to be
towed
we we'll give you the when you're ready
yeah the scarf that's fine we we'll take
care of it don't
[Music]
worry New Jersey Yankee 82 kilo Julia
Yankees say silver BMW it's gr all
right2 what' you
say my hands are shaken it's your first
arrest no it's not my first arrest my
hands are just
cold that part's under
[Music]
48 where you
going all right I just I'm tightening
your uh cop serus so they don't Tighten
Up On You
it's not but
okay how about close your jacket yeah
okay do you have anything in your
pockets
it3 okay yeah yeah I have it okay Jack
back I I have to I have to patch you
down first you're going right in the car
in a second anyway zip that up I have to
patch you down first to see if you have
your wallet I have to remove it from
your pocket it's in that pocket okay
I'll get it in one
second
this this pocket yeah what's this
lipstick or something that's not your
wallet have a gun LIC I'm a Democrat
it's not a gun it's lipstick or I don't
have Chapstick what is this Vape it's a
vape okay that's not your wallet is it
no I'm a Democrat
please
relax
will you stand still please it's cold I
understand
that no you just hold on to this stuff
for a second look those are going to
have to stay with the car is this your
house key on here or apartment key no
it's a safe okay is it okay to stay with
the car
key the car key has to go with the car
is this key okay telling it yes ma'am
yeah it has to be
to which one's repl is this key have to
go
here compy uh I'll find out when the
when we find out who's uh answering the
to there's two companies
in I will provide that info to you
before you leave
us all right we're going to take a walk
back this way okay no no no don't this
way this way right here this this car
[Applause]
here just stay there for one
second what you that thank
you actually the person who I'm calling
they're in my cell phone okay where is
your phone is it just hold on one
second I don't have a phone is your in
your
car no case is an iPhone or Android
phone iPhone 13 Pro iPhone 13 Pro you
you want me to get that for you yeah
this careful watch the curb watch your
head thing right
here the seat belt yeah I have to bug
the seat belt right
the cffs they stay on until we get back
to the station
okay
thanks um yeah I yeah I don't give you
permission to search my car so we we you
don't have permiss we do we do get
permission um based on the arrest to
search for intoxicants um and then we'll
grab your phone so you have your the
phone number okay well we'll we'll
determine that okay you want to call my
l
no you guys want to uh K sign 11 for uh
yeah for intoxicant she said her phone
is in the console here she wants us to
get her phone for her yeah okay that's
fine yep the uh I'll I'll grab her phone
uh I'll take it back with me you have
the key right y okay
um yeah that's good and then you guys
just sign 11 for toxic please
[Applause]
11 on the I have your phone
here all right 4 I can't hear
you do I have your lawyer's phone number
why would I have your lawyer's phone
number I can't hear you have my lawyers
no I do not why would I have your
lawyers phone number I don't give you
permission to sech car B we are allowed
to search your car for intoxicants being
that you're under arrest for drunk
driving okay for what for drunk
driving 515 237 copy on a
cherapy
One Whiskey Fox Dr 34 to 30 mileage is
111.1 car
six
this is not my hand right I'm
sorry what' you
say what about your
hand are you smell something F search it
right the vehicle be because you're
under arrest for driving well
intoxicated we search your car for
intoxicants yeah okay so that's what
they're looking for what what did you
find I didn't find anything I'm
obviously here with you they're looking
in your car okay did you say something
about your hand I did you did you slip
out of the cffs or no no no okay all
right no I'm asking to call my lawyer
okay we'll we'll talk about all this
when we get back okay just call them
right now
we're not doing that right now okay
that's actually hold on one
second okay well we can resolve this in
court I
don't
what' you say
Serge I
know I'm so wrong
all right here you're going to hop off
for me why' you undo your
B hold on wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait stop
stop call my
water nothing okay all right relax stop
wigging just stand still there another
pocket
okay